okay so the Chapel Hill shooting I'm
learning about it at the same time as
you're learning about it if you're
watching this right off the bat an
absolute tragedy and my thoughts and
prayers go out to the families of the
victims that being said the media's
already started to circle and you're
seeing this up all over online people
saying well they're not the media isn't
talking about this because it's a white
guy if he were a Muslim it would be all
over the place of course they are
they're covering it everywhere don't
believe that first they are covering it
everywhere that a white atheist shot
three Muslims this idea that only Muslim
terrorism is covered as is completely
untrue
right now go to any major news website
this guy wasn't Muslim actually I'm
looking at the right scoop calm right
now um by all information that we have
that we don't have enough information
yet he was a hardcore anti religion
atheist progressive fans of he was a fan
of HuffPo Rachel Maddow Freedom From
Religion Bill Nighy gay marriage groups
a bunch of antique conservative groups
that's what we know so far it's not
conclusive so before we get into all the
conjecture that you're going to see from
the media I think something that is an
important takeaway here is that religion
despite what people have told you for
years is not the cause of all violence
or Wars evil is we see that today the
root cause for acts of evil is evil now
I've argued for a long time that that's
why since this incident has happened and
you're watching this video there have
been many many fold more attacks in the
name of Islamic terrorism than this one
attack globally every minute of every
day and I would argue because the root
of Islam is Muhammad and Muhammad's evil
that's an opinion if you disagree with
me you can comment below the root of
Christianity I would argue Jesus is good
I know people who the Inquisition the
Crusades okay today a vast majority of
charity and and humanitarian work is
carried out by Christians across the
globe
as to whether this guy you can see the
Chris Rock or Sally cone tweets will put
those up here saying they're just
calling him a white guy they're not
calling him a terrorist they're calling
him a man okay it's not a Muslim thing
it's not just because he's white and
he's not Muslim though I find it funny
when they equate white with Muslim
Muslim is not a race it's its religion
in an ideology we don't know his motive
it could be a senseless act of violence
but terrorism is not a senseless act of
violence because by definition it's
politically ideologically motivated it's
a means to a political end so why is
Islamic but why're Islamic murders
generally referred to as terrorism
pretty quickly usually they're committed
after the motive has been stated Allah
Akbar releasing a beheading video saying
we will bring Sharia to the world it's
really easy to tell the motive when a
guy says this is my motive I want
everyone who's non-muslim to die that's
terrorism by definition if this was a
tiff over a parking spot we don't know
it's a senseless act of violence if he
killed people solely because they were
Muslim it's wrong and I would have no
problem calling it terrorism has nothing
to do with with white or or brown it has
to do with the very definition of
terrorism and for uninformed people to
complain about it or to develop opinions
on either sides until we know the
motivation behind this its media
malpractice and you see that everywhere
so again what we're learning this as it
unfolds follow me on Twitter go to
ladder with Crowder we'll be covering
more of it but but the real takeaway
here is again we've been told that
religion is the cause of all Wars and
violence it's not evil is the root cause
for acts of evil is evil
is what I would tell you if I knew that
you liked this video but since this is
the Internet and I have low self
confidence please love me